all right so I wish this was a picture
situation where we could all take a
picture with a Swedish creature but it's
not done this is on Jimmy Kimmel
tomorrow night we go down there at eight
o'clock in the morning this is our last
chance there's a lot to do we decided
when the giant creature to go with an
epoxy mold it gives the best results in
foam rubber you have a nicer surface the
skin looks cleaner you get far more
detail from the sculpture itself with
epoxy your mold will last longer and
then will glass over that will cut it
off pop it off and then give that
fiberglass
to the mechanics so they can start
making the facial mechanics for the
creature and then we'll make sure the
grunting core is clean and then once
that's clean once the mold is clean it
goes into the foam room and then they
can run the phone skin
we're gonna inject this thing completely
the exact opposite of what you see here
we're going to have it upside down we're
gonna shoot it from the core what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to create a little
tea inside here so we're going to shoot
the foam this way it's going to hit the
tea split this way and then come out to
injection holes at the same time the
foam will rise
his hand is huge
tomorrow's gonna be pushing everybody
but everything is almost so close to
being there I saw you know seeing
everything it's the arm onto a now it's
massive you see the chest that we
painted you know no problem tomorrow
it's gonna be just you know another
deadline which will we meet everybody
feel good about Tuesday night
it's been a great crew everybody's been
collaborating and helping each other out
and coming up with great solutions to
problems that we're facing so all in all
I think it's been going really well and
I think you know the final product is
going to show that
I'm kind of making little comics and
little X's in there just try not to make
them all the same a little more organic
we just got to be really sure that we
got all the details we can get in there
it's funny you end up telling a story in
your head about what this thing's been
doing and where it's been and it's not
stupid but I look at stuff driving into
work today was a trash truck you believe
or not I was looking to the side of the
trash truck thinking look where all the
dirt goes it's kind of second nature now
but that's kind of what you do you have
to observe stuff in the real world and
try and use those observations your
paint job otherwise it didn't have the
same character
but I'm so happy
close to the end I don't know what I
expected you see a little design and you
look at it you know okay but once you
see it in the big almost completed
stages in it and it is 15 feet tall and
it has an arm the size of a car it's
just wow look at that
it's insane we built that I think people
are gonna wonder and who's in it how
they doing it how much is it weigh right
next to you it's really big
I think it's gonna be a pretty
impressive viewing for this one this is
live in your face there's no tricks here
it's just the full-on animatronic
costume slash puppet I think it's gonna
blow people's minds after two weeks of
design six weeks of building we were
ready to go to comic-con when I saw this
thing come to life today can't believe
it I mean I knew it that was the point
when I think everybody looked around and
went oh he's alive check out the wired
Channel the scene calm for the entire
giant creature series